Not today, Dragoons.
Not today.
I did it.
I've done it.
A lot of you didn't believe me.
One of you built a website to not believe in me.
But I proved you all wrong.
I have been early, not just on time, but early for five
streams.
Oh, wait, sorry.
Four streams in a row.
So, not today.
No punishment.
I told you, there was no point in thinking of a punishment
because I would be on time every time for the last week.
And I've fueled by spite.
wrong.
We'll get you one of these days.
Well, too bad.
The opportunity is gone now because I just needed to survive
until Saturday.
Today is the last Saturday stream.
I've done it.
I fucking did it.
1 12 30 stream uh that was where i felt like i i was like
i'm so i but but it worked it worked i i made it i made it
to the end patria said thank you for the magenta soup but
thank you thank you 100 i actually didn't believe in you at
all you have my apologies i have some codex system update
now thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you
i've done it oh my god well today we're gonna be playing
today's last day of halo 2 because we're gonna be finishing
the game today whoa but before i start let's do some life
updates do you guys see everyone i was browsing through your
twitter do you guys see about that typewriter battle royale
game like i wanted to play when at first like the early
access came up i was like i'll wait for the full release
because it's like early access and apparently it's a really
short early access too so uh the final game finally released
yesterday so it's basically like you're you're in a it's
just seeing how fast you type but it's like battle royale
like it's like that that that online the online one where
you race against other cars or some ship by writing uh but
like it's on a typewriter and it's just like it's like a
battle royale so they start eliminating people that look
like the slowest ones who have like wpm or some shit they
just start like killing them off until there's just one left
and it's so fun i was reading reviews because i was planning
on playing next week at the game i'm playing next week oh
yeah it's typing out the dead pvp basically so but you're
like in a room full of other players instead of just like
one v one and um it was so funny because and they're like uh
they're like oh my god there's so many cheaters right now
they gotta do something about the cheaters in this game and
i was like the game just came out like yesterday the game
just came out two days ago why would you there's no rank
points it's literally a it's like a friend slop game
technically because like you can play with a group of your
friends there and I was just like what do you I guess it's
like the enjoyment of cheating like because I was just like
there's no rank there's no fucking top 500 lobby you're just
typing like it's like for the fucking live love of the game
I was like why are the cheaters already in this lobby like
like what do you get out of it like literally just cheating
for the love of the game because there's no rewards there's
no they have no rank yet they're getting ready they're
practicing right now for for the ranking system um so i was
just like what's the point like apparently it's like a
really like it's like a really bad problem right now in the
game too So I'm just like I was just thinking like There's
nothing You get nothing out of it You're just typing
They got test out of the cheese for the real deal They got
to get there They just want to ruin it for the others But I
don't want one but others must lose Like there's no rewards
It's literally just that game but that's like that might
come out i don't know if you guys saw it but uh disney is
planning on doing on making an extraction shooter similar to
arc raiders with like i don't know if it's like with disney
characters but like i was like with i was just like disney
and i'm just like what are you gonna play mickey mouse he's
like uh-huh don't shoot yeah so like like in my In my head,
my first thought would be like Disney characters as In the
extraction shooter, but I assume they're trying to make it
like its own IP, but I feel like it would make more sense I
guess it would be star.
I would make more sense of those Star Wars, I guess for it,
but like I was just thinking like Oh my god, you could play
as Mickey Mouse gunning down goofy As he's trying to extract
it like, please Mickey, I just want to extract my loot and
he's like Not today, Kofi.
They were like, gosh, Mickey, rest me.
It's like, Dom.
I was like, you can recreate Dom.
So, so, so I was just like, oh yeah, and then also they were
trying to buy Epic, dude.
They were way, they're like, apparently, um, sources were
saying, that um they've been waiting for epic to do worse
because they're like because epic apparently had to fire a
lot half there's like not half but like a lot of their staff
members in epic had to be fired or some because they were
downsizing and disney has been like prowling in the
background like yes fire more yeah because they want to buy
fortnite disney wants to own fortnite and i if Disney owns,
I really, I don't know.
I'm not really feeling the whole Disney-owning Fortnite
thing.
I don't know.
I don't think I trust Disney to handle Fortnite.
Yeah, so, especially when they'll be able to have, like, a
lot of IPs as well under Fortnite because of the
collaborations and stuff like that.
But, like, so it's going to be interesting if...
Just ends up buying Epic.
Also, speaking of Fortnite.
Oh, my God.
I just got this email today.
Wait, actually, let me reread this email.
See if I can, like, talk about it.
But it's nothing to do with, like, Fortnite exactly.
Oh, um.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
So, yeah, uh, I received an email, like, today about it.
Uh, actually an hour ago.
It was, like, an hour ago, because I was, like, checking the
business email.
even though I don't have to I just like reading them
sometimes um um because like you know it's like a little ego
boost where he's like oh look at this company they reach out
to me oh my god I feel oh my god me I'm so important anyway
so I you know to just boost my self-esteem a little bit you
know when I'm feeling like a little down and like an email
is like oh my god oh it's me
anyway so uh I received this email like an hour ago and
apparently one of the uh one of the lead visual effects
artists from the Daft Punk experience reached out to me and
was like thanking me for uh playing the um you know playing
the event during when it first came out and he was saying
how like, oh, saying that my reaction particular made the
long hours working on it like feel like was so worth it.
Like, and I don't know, it just felt really nice, you know,
like being like, oh my God, like, you know, some of these
people actually watched my reaction to it and then how they
felt like, like, you know, all that work they put into it
was like so worth it for them because like what my reaction
and that like you know that really was like oh like i was
like oh my god oh my god really it's so thoughtful yeah and
it's really cool because it's like one of the people that
actually worked on the daft punk experience and you know
they put a lot of love and cleric care but there's so many
easter eggs um to like previous uh to like like call back to
like previous daft punk stuff too so you know it was like
you know someone who's also a huge fan of daft punk as well
and they're like thank you for being a fan And I'm like,
I've waited so long for a death book counselor.
I was like, thank you.
That's the only way I can experience death book.
So I just thought that was like really cool.
And it was like really nice of him to even like email me
about it.
And just saying like, thank you for, you know, you know,
playing the game and checking out the Dappunk experience and
everything.
I just wanted to say, no, thank you.
Thank you for making it.
And for making, you know, just making the experience so
amazing, like so true to Dappunk and everything.
And, like, you know, doing it for all those fans that have
been waiting for so long for a concert.
And, like, this is the best we can get now because they're
retired.
And we'll never get one.
And this is the only thing we can have now.
you know thank you to to them for making it for all of us
for all the death bug fans up there um anyway let's finish
hato 2 yeah all right let's go it was really good i just it
was honestly i love all like like the songs they picked and
like how why is that on my second monitor god i hate it why
is this on my second monitor Oh
But yeah, thank you for making such an amazing thing for all
the Daft Punk fans out there Burdick.
Well, thank you for 10 gift dishes.
Thank you.
Thank you You know, we're starving and we've been like
starving for so long We were finally fed It's been so long
Hello, please There we go.
There we go.
Now I have it on my main monitor.
All right.
Now.
Now it's on my main monitor.
Thank God.
We're so hungry.
But it was so worth it.
The weight was so worth it, though.
All right, here we go.
It's the final countdown.
Final countdown.
Oh, I can't wait to get the secret ending where Arbiter and
John Halo are alone to get in a room.
And then, oh, my God, Arbiter, where is that hand going?
Guys, I can't wait for the secret ending every week.
buddy i almost forgot holy shit takes three slashes i don't
really wait where did he go holy no he's he's berserking oh
i thought he would die before and then they start and he
warts at him and then and then john halo is like what and
then arbiter was like what and then john was like oh you
can't wait to get that secret ending guys
You know, because then, you know...
What the fuck?
Oh, he's grenading.
I was like, where's that?
Okay, guys.
Okay.
He's...
I am the...
I am the elite.
I'm literally the arbiter.
And then...
And then you find out.
they were more in common than they think nice all right
we'll just there's whoa where did he come from all right
always forget I have grenades when I start playing all right
we go invisible and then we kill him there's okay that's
illegal He didn't die right away!
Okay, I thought I hit him once and I thought he died.
That is my bad for thinking that I killed him right away.
That was my...
Wow!
Where did he come from?
Alright, that's it.
Oh, I have no nades.
Never mind.
okay and then oh my god okay it's fine i headshot him with
my knife it's fine knife headshot okay now i have names oh
wait i fucked up i fucked up my cloak give me a sec we gotta
recharge
all right now it's self-time
oh do do do do I leave now.
Maybe I should have slashed and then...
I should have slashed and then...
Oh, shit.
He's got me coronated!
Unless... Ha ha!
I got you coronated!
Alright.
That's right.
All your men are dead now.
Okay, I need you to turn...
No, no, no, no!
Okay.
Alright.
I got a little worried there.
But everything's fine now.
Everything's fine.
Nothing to worry about.
Where are my gospel music?
Oh!
Alright.
Self-tape.
I don't know.
like that are you fucking kidding okay it's fine all right
we need this actually too oh hey friend oh friend
okay how good is he in war
wait how good is he in he tanky enough?
Because my knife does need to recharge.
All I'm saying, I do need to recharge my knife.
I...
Is he a good enough fighter?
He is.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It was zero bullets.
I thought there were more grenades in there.
Hey, Dougie, crazy question.
But wouldn't you want to have happened to have gotten
curious and checked some Halo tags or something?
No, I actually have not yet.
That's your answer.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Dougie, please keep your fanfic to the website.
What do you mean, fan fiction?
Do you not see what we saw in the...
on the cutscenes did you not see the fucking tensions
between them when he was like what are you doing there John
Halo and John Halo was like um what are you doing yeah and
then oh the tension thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you oh I don't have names it's alright It's all right,
my jackals got this, right?
My jackals got this, right?
Oh, God, please let me kill him.
Please let me kill him.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, are you fucking kidding me?
Wait, evil jackal?
Oh, my God, I forgot jackals are evil.
My bad.
I forgot the jackals.
I keep thinking that.
they're, like, part of my team for some reason.
Like, I feel like the Jackals are the ones that should be
part of... Okay, I don't...
I need your knife.
Okay.
Um...
Hmm...
Okay.
Thank you.
I know.
I know it's the Grunts, but I always feel like... I was
like, don't worry.
Oh, yeah.
This guy, too.
I had to do that.
Oh my god, who's shooting at me?
Oh, shit!
Alright, nice.
He's still dead.
There you go.
Or five.
Oh, my god.
That guy fucked his wife.
So he's even more mad.
He's like, he's been waiting for this day for so long.
There you go.
Nice.
I would like the little carbine soon.
Alright, what?
Alright, we've kept moving.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay, he's dead.
Oh.
well actually yeah i don't need to waste my knife for this i
don't know i don't have any i don't have a charger i forgot
to bring my bat my sword charger guys i can't waste it on
these little guys on the jackals jackado thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you blue eyes thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you he was my lover blue eyes
thank you the super chat I would like new guns.
Alright.
Maybe I can...
I think I can.
Nah, I didn't hit him.
Where does this go?
Nowhere.
Alright, that's cool.
Actually, I'm just gonna do this.
This might be easier.
Mueller might be easier to kill him.
Oh, shit!
Alright, we wait.
We wait.
oh yeah for uh it's it's fueled by prayer i just gotta keep
what killed me what i don't even know what killed what the
fuck killed me what oh sorry i didn't have enough faith i
guess i didn't have enough faith i didn't believe hard
enough oh my god i forgot that's a That's the exploding box.
I forgot the boxes explode.
I haven't seen them in so red.
Gosh, if you guys didn't know, red equals explodey boy.
Holy shit.
There's a lot of people in the...
I thought it was two.
Oh, thank you for coming down now.
I thought it was two guys.
It was...
It was not two guys, by the way.
It was, it was maybe like three.
All right, bro, stop tanking that.
All right, now that I know this explodes, hello?
Hello, I was told that this explodes.
Does it explode when I made it?
Oh, it explodes with me.
That makes more sense.
You know, that makes sense, actually.
Oh, now you give me a checkpoint.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
All right, we just got away.
Hey, you want to drop down?
You really, you love dropping down earlier.
Would you like to drop out?
Fellow, fellow aliens?
Would you like to drop down?
Oh, okay, that's fine.
He dropped out.
All right, let's see if I...
There we go.
At least that one shot.
I think of a super chat.
Thank you.
Ever since you mentioned drinking a London fog, I started
making them a smile.
I'm glad to say my Kami Oshi didn't lie.
That they taste good.
I know.
I told you, London fog.
The fog is where it's at.
It's, like, better than coffee.
Because it's, like, tea.
And it has caffeine in it, anyway.
Wait, where did I drop this?
I fucking love London Fallout.
For those who don't know, it's just Earl Grey with vanilla
extract, and it's so good.
It's healthier than caffeine.
Oh, nice.
Thank God.
My lead has unlimited.
There we go.
Unlimited names.
Alright.
Yo, everybody.
I made it.
It took me 20 loops to get here.
Good?
Good.
Okay.
good alien not good alien there we go i don't know why he
stayed there all right you guys hear kochella kochella
started yesterday i forgot about kochella ever since like
covid like ever since covid like kochella has been like as
hype but this year apparently this year kochella there's
like so many people there because um the headliner is
literally oh shit I forgot they could walk up the stairs.
But the performances seem really hype, though.
I was looking at clips of it.
Clips seems...
All the clips so far of it seem, like, really fun.
People were camping, bro.
Like, oh my god.
Apparently, like, to camp at Coachella is, like, 12 to 15k.
For, like, the good camp, like, for the...
or like the good tents where it doesn't feel like you're
camping wait I accidentally killed him quote-unquote camping
like I saw like a tent tour they're like this is what this
is my tent for Coachella and they have like literally like a
miniature AC unit like a giant solar power panel to charge
all their stuff um an actual bed uh they brought like
fucking beds to the tents and shit they're just shitty hotel
like they're just hotel rooms but they're outside yeah
it's crazy i was like what the fuck
like it's like i brought my dinner like here's my juicer and
i was like wait like i'm still trying to be healthy while
i'm here at coachella so i brought my juicer and uh my mixer
here i'm like oh my god wow camping for coachella goes hard
as long as they don't know that the stairs exist but
apparently it's because like the reason why everybody's
freaking about Coachella this year is because Justin Bieber
is a headliner for oh creepy nut creepy nuts was one of the
uh one of the uh performers it was really cool to see uh
that they invited like Japanese talents there I don't know
if like uh there this year and it was like creepy nuts was
there and then you see the audience sing along to like dan
danan and also to like bing bam bam bam bam bam it was so
cool I saw um yeah it's the people that made the and the it
was really cool to see and the audience were just like
actually knew the lyrics to it too
but anyway the reason why like Coachella right now is like
everybody's talking about it on my timelines because Justin
Bieber is one of the headliners and all the believers are
now old enough to go to Coachella and like I guess do a lot
of job Can't wait for Woodstock 29.5.
They give a super chance.
Thank you, thank you.
He still performs.
He got paid $10 million.
Anyone will still be performing.
If they were paid that amount of money, they're like, sign
me the fuck up.
I'd be like, I'm not retired.
Like, yeah, apparently he's the highest paid headliner
talent for Coachella so far.
Yeah, I'd get on stage.
He'd fucking go out of retirement for that.
But yeah, apparently it's today.
It was funny because a lot, like, it was literally,
apparently the Believers have been, like, waiting, because,
like, his performance is, like, what, at night or some shit,
and, like, they've been waiting for him to perform since,
like, um, since, like, 1 p.m., and I was like, holy, oh,
hey, oh, now you're here.
What?
Oh, them.
I was just like, what did I do?
They're, like, think your betrayal?
I'm like, what did I do?
I've just been shooting.
I've been doing what you want me to do.
I've been shooting these guys.
That's why he's like, hey, where did he go?
Where are you going?
Oh, shit.
They can finally, yeah, they can finally stay past their
bedtime.
Oh, that is not good.
Okay, let me chop him up.
oh he had a shotgun he had a fucking okay all right he had a
shotgun okay that all right all right he's not ready for the
fucking shotgun i guess i don't worry i'm just chopping up
chop him up like i've been doing okay that's all right you
go take he blew my he actually shot my head
all right i'll shoot your head off there we go
i think the i thought it was oh yeah and i don't know if you
guys know like the dutch singer josh i think that's his name
but he sang crazy frog that's so funny he sang he sang crazy
frog at gochella he's like It's like a bomb bomb.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Oh, my God.
The guy who said Euro Papa.
He's apparently, like, if you're European, you'll know who
he is.
But the non, because he's from Eurovision, he's also a
really popular Dutch singer.
And he did, I really like Euro Papa.
Euro Papa is such a, uh, uh, what's the word?
It's a really good song to sing along, too.
Ah, it's like an earworm.
What's that word for, like, a song that's, like, just, like,
easy to sing, too?
You know, papa.
There we go.
Let's see it.
Also, why does the...
Why do the brutes have a fucking human shotgun?
Hello?
I remember...
I'm pretty sure the aliens do not have...
Have not invented shotguns yet.
Yeah, yeah, it's very catchy.
Yeah, oh, they stole it.
I was gonna say, where the fuck did they, where the fuck did
he get a shotgun?
Those were our not prayer bullets.
What?
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot you were not.
I keep thinking he's firing my team.
See, look at this.
Look at what they did to me.
In the past, I thought all aliens are bad.
And now, like, they reprogrammed me.
And now it's fucking with me.
Why are you?
Because I'm an orbiter.
Now it's fucking, fucking with me now.
I don't know who to shoot no more.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
What is this boss fight music?
Wait, no, they're part of my team.
Oh, I should be driving the car.
I'll just ride past this.
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
I'm a random bomb I don't buy no bomb bomb bomb bomb bomb
bomb bomb bomb bomb bomb bomb bomb Flip flip to save me flip
to save me.
Oh shit.
Okay now the it's all right.
It's just a flesh wound The music's out there like this is
too embarrassing for us.
We're gonna go now.
We're gonna...
The muse, the bad left, they're like, this is too
embarrassing to watch.
Wait.
Kill him.
Okay, it's fine.
it and the band said nah we gotta go now it's fine it's fine
we made it to the next stage like that fucking music went on
for like one minute and then the band left i was like i
still have the rest of this map to go through like why did
you leave i'm not done with this map yet oh shit I just
thought I flipped the car.
You skipped.
Why would I fight when I could just drive through it?
Why?
Do they expect me to fucking do a pit stop?
I'm trying to save the world.
I'm trying.
I'm literally trying.
I'm trying to save the world right now.
Why am I wasting ammo to fight?
them.
Look, okay, look, I shot him.
I shot him.
Are you guys happy?
Cowered mentality.
Why give me a car if they want me to fight this?
Okay, now I think I'm supposed to fight this because where
the fuck do I go?
Oh, here.
There we go.
Wait, I'm left.
No, I thought I thought I could go through this.
The world can't wait now.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'll fight this now.
So you can have...
Look, see it?
Here, I shot at him.
I shot him.
Yes, I did it.
Okay, I'm poking.
Goodbye.
Park.
Oh, my God!
Oh, my...
Strat Oh shit Oh my god Strat It worked It worked
It fucking worked It fucking worked I didn't know how but it
worked Oh there's the shotguns I'm gaming Gamer Right here
Sonic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If it works, all weapons, that's a lie.
Where the fuck is my...
Oh, where the fuck is another sword?
I don't like how I don't have a checkpoint done, though.
I really don't like that.
Why is there...
Okay, four bullets.
Yeah, see the music returned.
They saw the aura.
They saw it.
Okay, we got recharged.
They saw the aura, guys.
Wait, I can get a sniper.
I gotta get the sniper.
It's every weapon except for the sword.
So is it truly every weapon?
Oh, I don't like that.
Actually, I could...
I could... Maybe...
Can I rocket launch that?
Chat?
test out the theory?
Can I blow that up?
Yes.
Okay, that's good to know.
Okay.
No!
Why?
I was so...
Oh my god, I have to do this all over again.
Oh my god.
I...
have to give me a sec.
I gotta remember how to do this.
I'm so sad.
I was so cool, dude.
Re-recreate it.
I don't know if I can recreate it.
It was like a once in a lifetime.
Okay.
Wait, I could do this.
No!
I'm so sad.
I had so much aura.
The bad came back too.
The bad came back.
Why did you go back outside?
I saw I could, I don't know.
I really thought I could do it.
Wait, wait, wait, I could do it again.
can do this again what the fuck guys i don't think i can get
in the room
okay is he still alive okay all right is he still alive
corner peak
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, what happened?
Did he spawn?
They're like, this is embarrassing.
I'm leaving.
Did he...
They left?
Why did they leave?
What?
It was the fight of the century.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Alright, they're dead.
I'm very scared.
I hope he doesn't see me.
I was just two shots.
Okay, I can't three shot this or I overheat the gun.
Is he dead?
Is he gonna run around again?
Like a little...
little monkey.
I'm so scared of that tank.
I feel like one-shot me.
I don't know where the entrance is.
You see?
Oh!
Okay.
This is fine.
What the fuck?
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
I got him.
All right, I got my new car.
I don't think the tank sees me this time.
Don't worry, I'm new turning.
There we go.
All right, new car.
New car.
Oh, shit!
Carby, car!
Don't worry, I got him.
I got him.
As long as my car doesn't blow up.
Which I think might actually happen.
Okay, it's fine.
He's going to come back, right?
There we go.
Okay, we got to grab this.
I have clue.
I should really use that more.
Yay!
We made it!
Oh, congratulations, Brady!
See, I told you to go all in.
Take the gav of Brady.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I am the new engagement.
The counselors, are they murdered by the brutes?
Violent, disloyal beasts.
The prophets were fools to trust them.
Isn't there still one more prophet?
Gory, they give a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That sounded like a joke scare.
All right.
There's the woman.
Yeah, there's only truth left.
My favorite gun in Halo so far.
I think it's the sniper.
Is either the sniper or the carbide?
They're both really good.
They're just both easy to headshot with.
Pussies!
Come back and fight me like a man!
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah, now he's part of the hive mind.
Where is he going?
Okay, he's, they've been choking him for like 20 years.
I'm surprised he lived that long, getting choked.
It's a forerunner ship.
And Truth is heading straight for it.
If he leaves the Covenant fleet to Earth, they won't stand a
chance.
You have to stop him.
That brood has the index.
And Miranda and Johnson, he can activate the ring.
i'll detonate in amber clads reactor just like we did the
autumn so the blast will destroy this city and the ring it's
not a very original plan but we know it'll work no i don't
want a chance a remote detonation i need to stay here oh no
katana but then i won't have voices in my head no more
oh oh the flood is here oh my god they can drive planes down
too Holy shit.
Wait, where did the flood go?
Were they not in here?
Oh, wait, they're in front of me.
I will let the brute finish them off.
We'll wait.
Oh, I don't even know if I can wait.
Oh, to like make their defenses.
Limit their defenses.
That's my ship, right?
That is not my ship.
They are...
Oh, my God.
That was definitely not my ship.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Little popcorn.
Oh, my God.
I was like, where's your head?
Where's your...
That's got the 20 plasma bullets.
I see you.
I can't even shoot him.
He's just stuck.
Oh, there you are.
Oh, he doesn't have a head.
He doesn't have a head no more.
Oh,
yeah, I forgot you're bad.
Oh, it's fine.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
You just got...
You're like, we got him, boys!
And then the shotgun from downtown.
Okay.
I should, actually.
I should actually grab the shotgun.
I saw what it did to that poor guy.
Wait, where is the shotgun?
No, where did I...
I don't remember where I killed him.
There's so many aliens here.
Where the fuck is the shotgun?
Oh, I guess there's no more shotgun.
Alright, the ship is right here.
on the bridge it's too late i'm not turning around is this a
ship i go on no it's running though oh i guess i don't know
how to drive it do i do i just not know how to drive it i
guess the current gray mine remembers everything about that
that everything that the one of how thousand hundred
thousand years ago knew Some of the green mines during those
times were made of the population of entire plants.
Oh, shit.
Oh, there it is.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's like...
What was that show is watching where...
Oh, it's like the Titan thing.
Where, like, the Titans remember all.
Alright.
I'm sorry, guys.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm I I'm sorry I'm Cortana do not see how many people I'm
fighting right now we don't have time for these games John
we need you to fucking get on the ship I'm trying Cortana
believe me I'm trying oh now they come up there we go
They're like, stop fooling around, John.
I'm like, what do you mean?
Okay, I should meet that.
Thank you for delivering that.
Women, am I right, boy?
All right.
Don't you hate it when your AI woman is rushing you?
It's like, oh my god, Alexa, I know I have to get there in
time.
God.
I'll disable this lift once you reach the top.
That'll slow them down, I hope.
Don't you hate that?
Shall we let the flood consume our holy city?
Turn high charity into an unknown territory.
No enemy has ever withstood our might.
A flood too shall fail.
You guys lost the last fight.
What the fuck do you mean?
No enemy has withstood us.
You literally lost to me in Halo 1.
Alright, up the elevator.
Oh, oh wait.
Oh, no!
Wait, take me back!
Take me back!
Wait, I did it!
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Oh shit, Zycon!
Wait, wait!
Wee!
No!
I thought I got away.
I didn't realize it was an actual elevator.
I thought I had time.
I thought I was gonna walk the bridge.
Alright, we wait.
We'll wait here.
I can wait here.
We'll wait.
Take me back.
I thought when I crouched into the second elevator, they
didn't see me.
Oh my god.
I'm hitting it.
This is like aim training right now.
I'm actually...
There we go.
I'm doing aim labs for this.
All right, the flood is still going.
We'll just wait.
Wait, does it stop?
Wait, does this do these stop?
Oh.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Why did they all just turn around?
Shall we let the flood consume our own cities?
Turn high charity into another of their riches.
I don't want to use the sniper though.
I mean, I can...
No enemy has ever been seen.
I alerted the horde.
And two shall fail.
I like the car about more than her sniper.
I'm going to keep that.
I'll do what I can to slow the launch sequence.
Guess who lost?
A presence that's fighting back.
For a covenant construct, it's unusually formidable.
no time to admire the view truth's phantom has reached the
forerunner ship okay i can wait here like they have to stop
right the hive has to stop okay here i think i can rush in
here there's not a lot of them now i'm pretty sure okay
there is a lot of them i'm gonna
a lot of them
backing up all right okay with this i take the elevator now
and then because they're still sniping that one guy you see
that and then i have camo where's my camo wait oh wait i'm
done i've just heard on my flashlight I'm blurring together.
I forgot I'm John.
I will see you.
I turned on my fucking...
Don't worry.
I have a flashlight.
I'm sniping those fuckers.
I was like, don't worry, guys.
I got this.
I thought it was John.
I thought it was John Harbin or not.
John Halo.
At this point, I'd rather the fucking...
Alright, there we go.
Oh, where you're going, little buddy?
Alright, round...
The second wave is coming.
There we go.
We saved them.
Let me get my car by now.
Alright, now I'll take the elevator.
all right i should have just done that in the first place i
just sniped the flies oh what oh they did all right
that is one tanky ass right there there we go like that they
don't care like that's good There we go.
Now we take the elevator.
As a population of 7.7 billion, the flood's currently
enjoying all you can.
What the?
Okay, there it's fine.
It's alright.
By the leg, I'm so hungry.
Thank you for the super chat, Caleb.
Thank you.
Yay!
Elevator.
Yippee!
Alright.
We made it.
Me and my trusty...
Me and my trusty flashlight.
There we go.
Ooh, I don't like how...
I don't like this toxic gas.
What is she...
Oh my god!
We have to go straight in!
Oh, no.
Look, look at the little floor pimples.
I need them to blow up real quick.
There we go.
The popcorn buddies.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Okay, that's not where I have to go.
All right.
Let's see the other way.
No, the carbide.
Oh, wait.
Actually, six bullets.
Oh, we'll go here for now.
Damn.
Okay.
Alright, back to my carbine.
Oh, hey, battle rifle.
I still think the carbine's better.
Kudos to him for tanking 20 shotgun bullets.
Alright.
Next stage.
All right, let's go back to get the battle rifle.
I have four bullets.
I have four left.
All right, back to...
I just gotta go back.
Where is it?
There's the shotgun.
Oh, no.
Did these spawn?
Wait, no, there it is.
Um...
Yeah, I realized there's no extra carbon anymore.
nobody's carrying a carbine gun you would think like more of
them would because it's one of the better alien guns out
there you know just in case I get oh I don't like that I
fucking knew it I knew it boom oh shit there was a lot more
than not expect it.
Slash the slash!
There we go.
Wait, he's still alive?
Oh my god, wait, how many are there?
Wait, they just keep coming.
Okay, we actually have to slash all of these, though.
So we gotta get rid of these pests.
All right, I wanted to... Oh, there we go.
I forgot which one was for a second.
Oh, we wait.
We can wait.
Wait, hello, excuse me.
Why are you shooting me?
I'm not part of this fight.
Parasite did not defeat the war.
And it shall not defeat us.
You'll never know.
I think they can't get me here.
Ah, hot girl.
Oh man, the music's getting quite ominous right now.
I will break your shield if it means I have to kill you
He's still alive Bro, your friends are dead because you're a
fucking coward
Oh Oh, there you go
It's getting a little spooky right now It's getting a little
spooky.
Did they get truth?
Oh my god, they got him, didn't they?
They got him.
Oh.
Do you have a shotgun?
No, he doesn't.
Okay.
Oh, you're not.
Nope.
No.
Get out of there.
Yeah, I'm gonna have to grab the rocket launcher.
I will wait.
Okay, maybe this is the bad time to have a rocket launcher
if the flies are here.
Oh yeah, they're like, join us, brother.
It's so cool.
Being united in the high, my.
Join us.
I need the...
Where did I throw my battle right?
Oh, there it is.
Got a swat some bugs.
Ten bullets.
Yeah, two corpses, one grave.
No regrets.
As they say.
Alright, JK, I forgot.
It's like...
Oh my gosh.
I wish I had my car behind right now.
Ten shots.
And a dream.
All I have is my flashlights.
Okay, the music is less spooky here.
I'm just hoping they fly closer to me.
Okay, this is very hard to do.
Wait, oh my god, you wait!
I was like, where am I getting shot from?
Like right upon, right behind you.
That's good, that's good.
That's actually good.
If they keep flying above me.
If they keep flying.
Yep, yep, you'll do.
There we go.
Yes, get closer.
Yes.
Me, the spot.
Yes, get closer.
All right, there we go.
It was that easy.
Oh, no.
I'm running out of battery on my sword.
I want them to know where I have to.
am chat really look at look at that i don't have i don't
have a sword no more though
i hope i can get another sword here it was so op i just
swatted them apparently these are the prophet hierarchs
private quarter their intersection
you deserve this
like literally i got this guys he's like pop oh shotgun he
literally just went pop i thought i got a carbine yeah
all right start the elevator it's like don't worry i have
movement then he's like movement's not gonna save you from
this All right, I don't have a lot of bullets for either, so
let's gotta make every shot count.
All right, let's hope I get covered.
All right, every shot's gotta count.
Reload.
Oh my god.
All right, every shot's gotta count.
Oh, I don't like that.
This crisis will not be the end of us.
It's but one last hurdle before the journey and selfish.
Oh my...
Wait, why me?
We have a common...
Oh, wait, the common enemy is me.
Sorry, I forgot.
A common enemy is me.
I was like, alright, we wait here.
We...
Okay.
Okay, now I have no bullets.
Alright, they're still fighting, right?
Yeah, I feel like the flood would be like...
Would one to not kill me.
If I'm stopping the ring...
You're right!
Are they dead?
Wait, who won?
Who won?
Oh shit, that is the flood one.
That's actually...
That's actually good for me.
Alright, that's good for me.
They got the...
They got the deal with the shield bullshit.
Thank god.
I feel like the flood would always win just because that
Just because it's just from sheer numbers alone.
Wait, where did he come from?
It's like, surprise!
They'll never expect this!
Alright, back to my big-ass door.
It's like the flood rush.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
I got my sword again.
I can't stall the launch sequence much longer.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I can't fight this faster.
Cortana?
Oh, is that lore?
Oh, wait.
No, that's just a door.
Aha.
Wait, what's the difference between...
I'm just double checking in case I might miss any lore.
Oh, it is lore.
Oh, it is.
I was...
Alright.
Nice.
Lore time.
I'm sorry they have so many different alien door designs
I've been losing track what is a door is one of both legend
and infamy their name has been corrupted by great shame
though the contemporary is perhaps the most confounding of
all Thel Vademy was born of noble blood the legendary house
of Vada his family's renowned demanded great expectations
for his military career and he would meet them all
wait are there any female worms i just realized are they all
just men one of the youngest to achieve the status of
shipmaster because he's covering his crouch right of supreme
commander in our campaign against the humans
world after human world all laid low for the sake of the
great journey there are females oh okay so I say do they
have boobs he failed his greatest charge and the sacred ring
was desecrated oh no such disgrace Delvedomy became is that
me am I failed me ascribe I do not challenge the word of the
hierarchs but i would be remiss not to voice concern this
saying healy should have been put down publicly slain as an
example to all of our prayerful expediency
yes army that's arbiter and the changing of the guard all
things are in jeopardy will this arbiter remain loyal like
writing my my story now people as they are abolished by our
newfound might i would never openly challenge the divine
proclamations of a hierarch but this arbiter is a risk i
would not have tolerated and i now forgot he had a name i
forgot he had a name i've just been calling him john arbity
i was like oh my god he has a name I'm writing my story
right now.
I hope obviously good things, right?
He was talking good things about me, right guys?
In the beginning!
He was glazing me!
Yeah, he was glazing me in the beginning.
Surely he was still positive in the end.
For sure.
I knew the covenant was good at repurposing forerunner
technology, but this is it.
Totally.
They've been using the forerunner engines as an energy
source for the city.
I will just wait.
The ship isn't so much launching as it is disengaging.
Fight!
Stopping truth!
That's all that matters.
Now is the time of our unworlding.
The moment we shall all become.
As cause.
Oh no, the brutes won this time.
Oh wait, there's more of them.
Go!
Fight!
No, not me!
Not me!
They're like, oh, I heard fire.
I guess I'll go.
Okay, we're gonna go this way.
Oh.
I'll just run through everything.
Hello, Cortana.
Coming over, Cortana.
Remember where we said you gotta get on board?
I'm doing it, Cortana.
Oh, that's...
Bye.
No hesitation.
She's like, I can't buy.
I'm like, all right.
Chief, when you get to Earth, good luck.
Just say no more.
I'm the girl that promised.
If you know you can't keep it.
Goodbye.
Quick talk.
It's okay.
We can download her again.
She's in the cloud.
Don't worry.
I'll just, I'll redownload her in the cloud.
Yeah.
What is that place?
She'll be back, guys.
She always comes back.
There is still time to stop the key from turning.
I must get inside.
Then mount up, Arbiter.
I know a way to break those doors.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do you want to see female leads?
So if you can actually see some of them in one of the Halo
anime shorts.
And Halo Edge is recommended after Halo 3.
Wait, what car do I want to be on?
I guess this one.
Why is this is cool?
Which way?
Okay, I'll follow him.
He knows which way.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom.
There we go.
See, now I'm participating.
See, guys, I'm not driving past them anymore.
Oh, my God.
I swear to God.
I'm participating now.
My tank's faster, I think.
Wait, how do I do the mini-guns again?
I don't remember.
I don't...
I don't remember how to shoot the miniguns.
Oh, wait, that's getting off.
Get back in there, soldier.
Wait, but he has the miniguns.
That takes shot the miniguns on me.
It's not fair.
I need a buddy.
There's a buddy system.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
You live there?
I don't get it.
up there oh shit all right we'll just get closer because
like he'll just be oh never mind oh shit was that that's not
my teammate never mind that's good i didn't shoot my
teammate all right i need you to get a little closer or not
too close to me so i can shoot you guys There we go.
Flip.
Guys, stop getting...
That's it.
There we go.
That's on you.
I gave you a chance.
I gave you a chance to get back in the...
To back out.
He could have backed out.
Just in case.
Evil or good?
Evil.
Am I?
I'm not hitting it.
I don't know the...
I don't know the projectile, apparently.
Alright, fuck this.
I don't know.
I don't know the fucking...
The distance of my shots.
Oh, I'll get up there.
He's gonna fly away, right?
Eventually.
What are you doing here?
Oh my god, the whole too small.
Oh shit.
It takes okay, I got checkpoint.
Oh, get up.
Okay.
Beam me up.
Okay, it didn't beam me up.
Never mind.
Go back in.
But just in case, because I don't know if this tank is dead
yet.
Okay, now it's definitely dead.
It's fine.
My tank's okay.
Okay, he's definitely dead.
I had to double tap just to be safe.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
no why did you keep shooting me oh wait he was on my ship oh
I didn't realize he was on it I can't see the front of my
ship guys I didn't realize he was on the ship I can't see in
front of me okay
the other ship was body blocking um He was a big phone,
guys.
Oh, my gosh.
So insensitive.
He's working so hard to lose weight.
Alright.
Guys, he was working so hard.
What the fuck?
Hello.
Wait, are these?
Oh, hello.
Sorry, I didn't realize you were good people.
I'm sorry.
I didn't.
No!
Green, donkey, green!
They're just like, Hello, Arbiter.
It's nice to see you back.
And I threw a nade at them.
I was like, oh my god!
Don't worry, they'll survive.
All that armor.
They're like actually my meat shield right now.
These guys are actually my meat shields.
Holy fuck!
You're right, they should be used to it too.
You're right.
They're used to betrayal.
These are better than a tank.
Holy shit, they're some big boys.
That's right!
Oh my god Oh my god get away from that
That'll be fine They got one of them out
Them He has armor They were just lobbing fucking grenades
There's no way that fit into the fucking hole
There's no way that fit in the hole
There we go.
There's no way that fit in the goddamn hole.
I tried so...
It's so hard.
Oh, shit.
Alright, nice.
Oh, were they still there?
I did not realize they were still standing near the
explosives.
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait.
This is gay, they're still alive.
It's okay guys, they live.
They live, guys.
Guys, they lived.
Everything is fine.
It's like they never died.
It was just a dream.
It was just a dream, guys.
Oh my god, I think it was actually the sniper that killed
him.
Oh, yep.
Yep, it was definitely the sniper that killed him.
Where's the other sniper?
That actually makes more sense.
Yeah, they were able to get the whole...
here all right what the fuck wait but what happened to the
second one oh wait these spot i don't even know where the
second one died wait was there one of them had oh fuck it
whatever
it's all right at least they both died together guys that's
all that matters they died together
Hello?
Alright, bad guys.
There we go.
I'm glad they...
I'm very convenient.
How?
Holy shit!
I'm sorry, did I shot your gun five times in a row?
Your head was clearly peeking there.
Yeah, I was gonna say that was the tankiest one.
my god not the goddamn flies oh no no
okay i don't know okay let me make sure all the flies are
dead before before i move forward um all right here we go
god fucking god damn it those stupid goddamn flies
Oh my god, I hear them fluttering.
I hear those goddamn winged bastards fluttering.
I see you!
I don't even see you there!
Okay.
There we go.
That should be all of them.
Peekaboo.
A little peekaboo action.
there.
Alright, I'm ready.
Throw the next thing at me.
Uh.
No red dots.
Oh, there's the red dots.
But where are they?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, his shield is green.
Oh my god, I'm the arbiter.
I- I- I think it's just blurs all together.
John Halo Armadale.
I forgot.
It's just, they all blur together.
It's the same guy.
Now I remember.
There were no occasion where I had to use it.
Though to be fair, to be fair, I haven't seen it.
John R.
B.
Alright, two shots left.
One shot left.
It has to be the guy with no helmet.
There we go.
And now just throw this.
Alright, now I can grab my sword.
Is he the last one?
Oh!
There we go.
There go.
Don't worry, brothers!
Brothers, I am here!
Brothers, what do I do?
Oh, shoot it.
Okay.
Brothers!
Don't worry!
Oh my god, I could have just freed them.
Oh my god.
I could have made this easier for myself.
It's alright, it's alright.
I have more men.
Oh wait, that lore?
Wait, that's lore.
What's this over here?
Release them.
No, it's better at least to live.
What's this?
The only one I would trust with this information is probably
dead right now.
Free the lore!
He was commander of the fleet that brought me to the system.
Fel Vadimy was his name.
That's me!
After hearing you tell of the destruction of the ring, Wait!
But why did he shoot me then?
Why did the heretic try to kill me?
To prepare it for the arrival of the Hierarchs.
Vatami never fails in his duties.
We could have worked together.
Then Vatami must be dead.
Judy can indeed be a dangerous virtue.
He shot first.
You can't say I killed him.
Wouldn't this sense of duty make it quite unlikely to set
aside his allegiance to the prophets?
perhaps not and he would never betray my people oh my god he
was wrong if i if we were able to just speak to him explain
everything you have told me but no these are future hopes if
he did live and if he was returned to the they did not know
i was the arbiter they would certainly punish him for the
destruction of the ring like my voice the voice kind of
leader the Hierarchs would make Arbiter.
They would need someone to blame for the loss of the ring.
His influence within the fleet grew with every one of his
victories over the humans.
And if he did become Arbiter, then he would be lost to our
cause.
Without the knowledge you've shared with me, he would obey
the prophets without question.
I doubt he would even respond to his would take to overcome
he was willing to listen we don't have time to ask such
questions and vatomi is almost certainly dead if all your
hopes rest on him then i fear for the future of this galaxy
he caught a fucking fixed blade as do i he literally shot
first bro didn't even try others aware of the lies the
prophets whisper in our ears and soon we will find more who
will take up like we were like i'll be like okay i'll listen
and then he shot me why would i listen after that yeah we i
literally like lowered my gun and i was like all right bro
tell me tell me this tell me the story yeah he assumed look
at that guys assumption kills never assume guys
never listen.
But I was listening.
I was listening.
He couldn't trust an R, but there.
That's his own biases.
His biases.
What happens if I accidentally?
I'm curious.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Never mind.
Go.
Go, my people.
Please go faster.
Please.
Let's go.
I knew freedom now was a good idea.
I'll just wait.
You're doing it.
Alright, nice.
We won.
Very slowly.
Listen, you don't like me and I sure as hell don't like you.
But if we don't like you, wait.
Wait, what?
Wait, you don't like me?
Tartarus has locked himself inside the control room.
Well, I just happen to have a key.
Gonna know we're coming.
Oh shit, we're working together now!
Oh, there's the Banshee.
Yeah!
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
I forgot how to shoot this.
Fuck.
I don't know why I keep pressing every time.
Every time I press E.
I was like, I forgot to shoot this.
And then I press E.
I don't know.
I don't know why my go-to response is like, maybe E's the
shoot button.
My go-to is always E as shoot for some reason.
Is this ship killed?
Yes.
That's right.
Oh, I forgot they have the mini guns.
I shouldn't...
I shouldn't get too close.
Because with the logs, it doesn't hit anyway.
E for eject.
I don't, but it's like, for me, I feel like E for yous, you
know?
The E for use!
Wait, what's attacking me now?
Oh, right here.
Alright, we got three...
We got swap Banshees.
Wait, oh, fuck!
The E for...
Yeah, the E stands for shoot.
Please, let me on to this Banshees.
No way.
Like, one of those shots must hit.
Oh, no.
Oh, don't worry.
My plane is okay.
It's just...
Just a little flesh wound.
It'll recharge.
Flip!
Mirror!
There we go.
Let's go.
It's all right.
My plane is okay, guys.
It's okay.
Nothing to worry about.
It's very...
Oh my god!
Ah!
It's an airship, not a tank.
Do I have to kill them again?
Yeah, I do.
How the fuck did you survive?
Excuse me!
Okay.
I'm sorry, if I stay in the air, then maybe I'll live?
I need to remember to lead my shots for this.
I would really like Johnson's help right now.
That sounds like a good plan, Doki.
If I stay in the air, I should live.
Oh, shit.
Where's he getting shot at?
Oh, Pierre.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
Friendly fire.
I forgot about this one.
Are you serious?
It's hot.
Yeah.
I know.
I have a plan.
I have a plan guys There's a second ship
See guys It's like my bad sheep What was the other barrel
roll?
There was one for
What button was for the other barrel roll chat?
It's not E!
I know it's not E this time I I've learned Wait my plane
can't do barrel roll anymore why what did I do I know
there's two oh my god wait
you live oh my gosh he's doing a barrel row there you go
what if I just dock on top of this
I'll be safe now oh shit it's like the like the alligator so
like the ducks are docked on the the mama duck and i'm like
don't worry i've been safe now
it'll protect me from danger
Mama duck will protect me Oh no Wait, this is not good Wait,
this is not good
Oh no No
No!
No, my docking strat No No No It's all gone!
There you go.
I lived for so long!
It's okay, I can do it again.
It just works, guys.
It just works.
Oh, I'm gonna have to get on to...
Alright.
I'll just stay up here.
Don't worry, I'll cover you, Johnson.
Don't worry, I'm covering.
Don't worry, Johnson.
I got you.
I'm still so safe.
Pressing fire.
Holy shit.
It should eventually collapse, right?
All right, I just gotta look up in the sky.
We come from the sky.
As long as I look up, it should be fine.
I just gotta keep looking up.
There you go.
See, I told you.
Who would have thought planes come from the sky?
Oh, shit.
Wait, that one didn't came from the sky.
Where did that one come from?
Oh, maybe it shouldn't have been.
Oh, shit!
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
The ground bash you.
Don't worry.
Oh, my God.
Don't!
No!
Let's try to get on to the bad G!
It's not fair!
Where did he come from?
Oh my god, right above me as always.
Alright.
Oh my god, there's more arena.
What the fuck?
What's shooting me?
Do a barrel wrong!
Okay.
Get on it!
Arbiter, please!
All right, there we go.
Where did my Johnson go?
All right, I'm okay now.
Turn.
I'm okay, Johnson.
Don't worry.
He will save me.
fire holy shit it's alright they're almost dead I'm leading
my shot what Johnson you're supposed to cover for me Johnson
you had one jump I
don't know what's shooting me I really don't know there you
Johnson you get you get the ground I get the sky that's the
plan me sky you ground
okay there was one more there they are sorry they're
distracted I think I'm hitting them.
They're distracted, guys.
One of those shots will hit.
They're distracted.
I told you.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I still got it.
I still got the shot.
Oh!
Okay, Johnson.
Johnson, the tanks are there.
Johnson, Please, I can't cover ground and air.
Johnson, please.
We had a deal.
Johnson.
Oh, my God.
Please just stomp on them.
You're a giant spider.
Johnson, please.
Oh, God.
All right, one more.
Johnson, please, just one spot a leg.
Just one.
Just stop on it.
He's literally right next to you.
He's so stoppable.
Johnson, it is so...
He just needs to move his leg a little to the left.
Oh, my God, Johnson.
All I ask, I'd be sleeping on the wheel right now.
I will not be surprised if that is the case.
I will not be surprised.
All right.
There we go.
All right, we did it.
That should be all of them, Johnson.
Move.
Johnson, I killed them all.
Where are you?
Johnson, come on.
They're all dead.
Johnson, go forward.
Knock, knock.
Oh, now you shoot.
I wonder if I could die.
No, don't.
Don't go towards the light there.
He's like, ooh, shiny light.
wouldn't he be funny look at that shiny light
oh where's johnson going now oh time to go in he broke the
door
okay just remember i'm alright i can't see there you go i'm
john arbiter now so I can go invisible.
I just...
I don't have a flash net.
Let them enter the chamber.
The chieftain must complete his holy work.
Whoopsie.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, that's not the grenade I wanted.
How?
Wow, it's invisible!
Oh, no.
Oh, no, he has a shotgun.
My one weakness.
Okay, I just need to be sure.
Alright, I win.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
It's just rocket launcher.
I was like, surely I'll help somebody.
Oh, no, not another grenade.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, that is not fine no more.
My shield's recharging.
Watch this.
Boom!
Slash!
I'm still alive!
Boom!
Slash!
There you go.
I win.
Slash wins.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, yeah, I could run past them.
Oh, the one time I fight back.
You're like, Doki, you could just run past them.
Come, human.
It is easy.
Take the icon in your hands.
And do as you are told.
Please use caution.
This reclaimer is delicate.
One more word, Oracle, and I'll rip your eye from its
socket.
Which is nothing compared to what I'll do to you.
Oh shit.
She unripped two eyes from her socket.
Put down the icon.
Put it down and disobey the Hierarchs.
There are things about Halo.
Even the Hierarchs do not understand.
Take care, Arbiter.
What you say is heresy.
Is it?
Oracle, what is Halo's purpose?
Collectively all the seven.
Oh!
Please.
Oh, he knows.
Don't shake the light bulb.
If you want to keep your brain inside your head, I tell
those boys to chill.
Go ahead, do your thing.
The sacred rings, what are they?
Weapons of last resort, built by the Forerunners to
eliminate potential floodposts, thereby rendering the
parasite harmless.
And those who made the rings?
What happened to the Forerunners?
After exhausting every other strategic option, my creators
activated the rings they and all additional sentient life in
three radii of the galactic center died as planned would you
like to see the relevant data tartarus the prophets have
betrayed us blasphemy they would oh okay the great journey
has begun and the brutes not the elite shall be the prophets
escort oh Like, I won't be a sidehole no more.
He doesn't care if it destroys the planet.
At least he died as the prophet's bodyguard.
I'm sorry, Johnson will be okay, right?
Wait, I know this.
There's a speedrun.
I just need a...
Guys, I just need a truck.
I know the speedrun for this.
I saw it on SDGDPQDPPC.
give me the speedrun!
Someone just got give me the truck!
So like, how do I kill him?
I just know the speedrun of this, not the other way of this.
Can I cut him?
Oh!
That's...
Well, it will take some time to go over the cover of this.
Yeah, I was going to say, that looks like a shield.
That's it.
Johnson, I'm on it.
Hang tight, ma'am.
Wee!
Where did I get here?
Yeah, I need to spot 100 Johnsons.
Guys, quick!
Where can I spot a hundred?
I literally don't know how to...
I don't know what to do.
Oh, wait.
Oh, his shield's gone.
Oh.
okay guys i just need a car and a hundred johnson's and then
they'll be fine
oh shit okay there we go it's just me and you buddy how did
that go free i forgot to be camo for this
more knives for me.
All right, Johnson, do your thing!
Whoops.
We'll shut them down.
He's so angry.
Oh my god.
The shield's gonna leave any moment now, right?
Johnson, please!
Johnson, I'm on it.
Woo!
It's alright, I have a sword recharge.
He doesn't.
No!
Okay.
Okay, he knew, guys.
He might have known.
He might have known, guys.
all right we'll wait here i you know what i don't even know
why i fucking jumped down all right johnson let's try this
again wait what wait you're not dead all right johnson you
and i if only i have a thousand johnsons if only i only
remember that strat because of the the i just happened to
catch the speed run strat of that this one particular level
because i thought it was so funny i didn't even realize this
came from halo 2 i was like wait i know this i recognize
this from halo 2 from the speed run there's no way he can
reach me he can jump
Boom!
All right.
You'll just grab.
Oh, who's grab?
Oops.
Joss, I'm on it.
Hang tight, ma'am.
Not until that fruit is dead.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
i'm walking wait how am i getting shot wait who's shooting
me oh wait what where did he come from i didn't even know he
was here wait i thought i killed all of them what
oh i didn't realize more will show up all right he had none
of them spawned for so long.
Okay.
He's got the homies, apparently.
I'll just wait.
I mean, how am I supposed to do anything?
He literally has shields.
I have to wait.
There's nothing else I can do.
Johnson is taking his damn time right now.
Just don't use a sword.
Blast for me.
You could try shooting him.
Shooting?
This is a one...
This is a melee-v-vele right now.
He has a hammer.
I have a sword.
It's not about honor.
Johnson, I'm on it.
Where did he go?
Wait, keep ascending.
Wait, he ascended.
That's illegal.
Wait, what?
Is he allowed to do that?
Five!
Are you happy now?
I shot back.
I broke the rules.
Oh, nice.
Friendly fire.
Thank God.
You're telling me you can't stop the sequence.
Give me a direct answer.
I am.
Pop,
pop, pop, pop.
Pop, pop, pop.
So hard.
Like, how does he, like...
Oh, there we go.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you fucking...
Oh, come on.
come on the window is so short the window is so short for it
too feels like
all right we'll stay here we'll stay here it's all right i
have i can just wait here for until the shield oh my god
it's three seconds i will stay here if that's the case why
the fuck do i all right is it easier to tell if it's like on
i'll just wait here
uh we can both wait
we can those guys use swords look what happened to him toky
Come on, Johnson, shoot him.
Johnson, do the thing.
Do the thing, Johnson.
It will take some time to go over the proper procedures.
Quit stalling.
Under more controlled circumstances.
He's just... Johnson, shoot him!
Johnson, I'm on it.
Hang tight, ma'am.
Not until that brute is dead.
Johnson!
I hate...
I...
Why did that joke show up?
Why?
You have to sit here till you go down there.
This is bullshit.
Alright, let me see the shield.
I want to see how, if it's easier to see the shield dropping
down.
Oh my god, now he's down here.
So how is Johnson gonna shoot him?
What the fuck is, he's not even!
We'll shut them down.
It will take some time to go over the proper procedures in
the back.
Quit stalling.
Please, can you...
That's it.
Johnson, I'm on it.
Johnson, please.
What does he do?
I don't know!
I don't know what he's doing!
All right, how about we both?
How about this?
We take...
Here's...
You take the elevator up and then...
Oh No, is he stuck?
Is he stuck?
Let's see Oh my god, oh my god he baited me He baited me He
baited He fucking baited me Who killed me?
Who killed me?
Okay.
There's wins by doing nothing.
The last brood alive.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
We figured it out.
All right, Johnson, you got this.
right?
Oh, there we go.
How fast was that?
Oh, how do I stop it?
Well, it will take some time to go with the other
procedures.
All right, Johnson keeps shooting him.
All right.
Johnson, I'm on you.
Hang tight, ma'am.
Not until that brute is dead.
All right, there we go.
There we go.
Oh, no, I keep landing it.
It is easier to see the shield going down on this, on retro,
though.
Oh, fuck!
My plan!
No!
His body!
It is like his reinforcements came.
It was working.
It was working, though.
The fucking strat was actually insane.
Like, guys, the strat, though.
The strat was crazy.
Charging sequence initiated.
oh my god i can't i can't recreate it oh my god i can't
recreate it it is actually working too
okay let's see if i can recreate it i think i can i can
confuse the ai
Oh shit, the cheese!
The cheese, it's working!
You're telling me, you can't stop the sequence!
Okay, he's too busy with these guys now.
Okay, I need you guys to not be with me, though.
Oh, no.
The cheese stopped.
Wait, unless.
Hey, Mohawk.
How's that for you?
Alright.
We keep cheesing this forever.
Oh, not forever, apparently.
Your reinforcements are here.
I gotta go down to the pit.
I'll be right back.
kick that guy there i gotta grab the car oh wait i gotta
grab another car by
but your elite saw it working though
okay i'm gonna wait until
oh no he's coming
oh dope all right are we gotta set back our locations Shield
is down.
Let him have it.
A strat.
Oh, no.
Okay, nice.
I need to do it a strat again.
He needs to keep shimmying.
All right, there we go.
He's positioned perfectly.
He is not positioned perfectly for this.
There goes the shield.
We did it!
I just go...
We fucking did it!
We...
The cheese worked!
I don't want to see it.
It was that easy.
I understand.
At the moment, I understand.
I understood it when I was like, maybe I should stop using a
knife.
It all worked out.
Congratulations.
Greatest thing of a super chat thing.
Another halo down.
What's that?
A beacon.
What's it doing?
Communicating at super luminal speeds with the frequency
of...
Communicating with what?
The other installations.
Show me.
Oh?
In the event of unexpected shutdown, the entire system will
move to standby status.
All remaining platforms are now ready for remote activation.
Remote activation?
From here?
Don't be ridiculous.
Listen, Tinkerbell.
Don't make me...
Then where?
Where would someone go to activate the other rings?
Why the Ark?
Of course.
And where, Oracle, is that?
Oh, we're a team now!
Oh my god!
As humans in the Covenant are more in common than you think.
We got a new contact.
Unknown classification.
It isn't one of ours.
Take it out.
This is Spartan 117.
Anyone hear me?
Over.
Isolate that signal.
Master Chief?
You mind telling me what you're doing on that ship?
Try and tell me there's three halos?
Finishing this fight.
Oh, God, he's so cool.
Finishing the fight.
He said the lie.
We did it, guys!
We beat Halo 2!
Is this supposed to... Oh my god, I was gonna say it.
Oh, extra credit?
He's so cool.
Silence fills the empty graveyard.
Oh, he took... overtook the Covenant.
is not at rest for questions linger you
will ask and you will answer katana all right shoot katana
no she's gonna leak everything
oh no how do you how do you fucking make an ai a hostage
like she just turned just just Just turn off.
Just turn off the screen.
Cortana, no!
I suggest playing ODST as it takes place during 2.
How long is it?
Thomas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god!
She's gonna dox us!
She's gonna dox us all!
Just, yeah, just turn off the mod.
How can...
Wait, the flood can corrupt AI?
Bro, it's just...
data it's just numbers it's um a six hour okay it's six
hours all right that's fine we'll do it next time we'll do
it next time um but they can data is data bro did he like
insert the tentacle into the usb port or some that i feel
like that's a i feel like that's a dogen somewhere out there
Meep, thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Halo 2, what's next?
There's two halos?
What's next?
They're going to make three halos this time?
Cloud, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The flood is...
Yeah, but then wouldn't Cortana have like a failsafe where
like she just shuts down?
Just turn herself off.
Just turn yourself off and then like lock yourself out with
like...
He has to start hacking, right?
So then, like, Cortana didn't just put a failsafe Where she
just turns herself off And then have, like, you gotta insert
a password to unlock me You would think so You would think
she would have 20, like, at least 100 antiviruses And
failsafe just in case she gets kidnapped I don't know why
Chicana, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you
Congrats on beating Halo 2 Dokey for a cool extra You can go
to main menu to another day at the beach.
Also, do you think we'll get classic Halo game night with
dragons?
Maybe.
Maybe in the members.
Yeah, because we're always doing gaming streams with the
members.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, is this you working through, like, six proxies?
What kind of AI is this?
Your password is probably...
Your password is probably ABC123.
This was before they make you do, like, all add the symbols
and stuff.
There was no restrictions back then.
Let's see.
What was it?
What was, uh...
Go to Jakarta.
How did I have to go?
Jakarta said, extra videos.
Uh... Halo 2.
Where is the beach?
Unyielding.
I don't think I have it.
Oh, it said, oh.
Extra video.
Another day at the beach.
It doesn't seem like...
at the beach.
All that I have are the terminal.
Because AI only want knowledge and Green Mind has infinite
knowledge.
Shane, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, what's the last one?
Oh, do you mean the anniversary?
Oh, the anniversary cinematics?
Post credit.
I don't see it.
Day at the beach.
Oh, it was there?
Oh, there you go.
What's this?
This doesn't look like the best guys.
Look, that guy can do it.
That spider can crush it.
Johnson, that's what you have to do, Johnson.
It wasn't that hard.
He was able to crush it.
Oh,
he was able to fire the fucking gun, but not fucking move
left to right.
Oh,
shit.
It's okay.
He's not dead, right?
He's just down.
We better get moving.
What do you mean they're still alive?
Not Brian.
Yeah, Brian should have buckled his seatbelt guys
Where are the where are my space airbags?
Down means dead
Oh Sniper third floor left here.
Let me give him my welcome to earth gift basket
Nice.
Welcome to Earth.
Do you think they liked it?
Fucking cowards.
Fake footage, the tackle missed.
Oh shit!
Okay, he did not miss there.
Oh, the alien gun.
Oh, no.
Oh,
goodbye.
Well, you throw it!
Throw it!
Oh, that's so smart!
Do we see?
It would explode faster.
Take the shot!
Take the shot before he returns!
Wait, why do you throw him away?
He could have taken, he could have just Hold it.
Hold him.
And then raise him up a little bit so he gets shot at.
They did the combo.
Yeah, they did it.
They did the new combo.
Okay.
That worm was stupid.
He literally could have.
When they shot him.
He could have just brought up the guy.
Higher.
That's use him as a meat shield.
Stop helping the alien.
That was cool, though.
Oh, my God.
Why couldn't he do that?
Why couldn't my army do that?
Why did they make me...
Why did they make John Halo do all the work?
Why couldn't they do what they did in the cinematics in my
game?
Like...
For completing the first level on Legendary First Time.
No longer...
Think of the Super Chat.
Darius, thank you, thank you.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, because they're ODST.
They only do that there.
That's why you use protection when inserted into the USB
port so that you don't get viruses.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, they're way better than the Marines.
Oh, I see.
I see.
They're just a different... It's like the Black Ops.
They train differently from the regular Marines that got
drafted.
I mean, that makes sense.
Alright, guys.
We did it.
We finished Halo 2, everybody.
And I was on time for...
I was early, not just on time, but I was early for all my
streams this week.
That means I made it.
No punishment.
No fucking punishment.
That's right.
I fucking know...
A lot of you guys did not believe.
You're like, we're gonna pick up some punishments for your
dookie.
But I proved you all wrong.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We got some beating Halo 2.
It's great to see you get more comfortable with Halo
gameplay.
Thank you.
Super chat.
I actually started looking at my sonar radar now.
I started looking at the red dots.
I'm getting there.
It only took Halo 2 for me to start looking bottom left.
Hal, thank you.
Thank you.
Do you plan on watching the lore terminals from Halo 1?
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
I figured we got some of the terminal terminals.
Didn't we in Halo 1?
Because we're playing on the other...
We did play the first Halo.
I don't even remember.
We played first Halo on stream.
Jakarta.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, guys.
I'm gonna call it here, chat.
Like I said, I do have a lot of behind the scenes stuff
going on.
So I gotta go work on some work.
Go back to work now.
you all for coming thank you all for watching me finish halo
2 it was really fun it was really fun um the cinematics were
so cool uh the gameplay was very very fun uh annie thank you
for the magenta soup but thank you thank you mind telling me
what you're doing on that ship congrats on beating halo 2 it
was nice for visiting halo 2 all of a sudden i have a
craving for kebabs thank you for the magenta soup but thank
you thank you thank you thank you you were late You forgot
to account for daylight saving time and time differences for
your stream starts so hot But I was on time.
I said my time zone though.
We were talking about my time zone Wings.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Congrats on completing Halo 10 or making it early
the whole week to use.
Thank you.
Thank you Next week, current schedule, there is a sponsor on
Twitch next week.
There is, I'm going to want to play the typewriting.
Last sentence, I think that's what it's called, the
typewriting.
The writing battle royale, the typing battle royale.
And then maybe we'll start ODST.
I don't know.
Most likely, I feel like, I don't know.
Honestly, most likely, I'll start ODST and finish.
in one stream because it's like what six hours right so i
think i could do it in six hours uh unless you guys did
account for dokey hours right like the the dokey hours
because like if you guys say six hours i assume no uh the
only thing that's on twitch would be the the sponsor stream
that will be on twitch next week uh because apparently uh a
game one uh multiplayer shooter game is going to have a new
season soon Uh, so you know the drill.
You know it if you know.
I can't say what game it is.
But you know the drill.
Let's see.
Uh, but yeah.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna call it here.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get them
moving around, get that blood flowing.
If you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Oh, yeah.
Most likely, there won't be a sat...
Wait, let me see.
I need to know.
There won't be a Friday, Saturday stream.
I will not be here on Friday, Friday, Saturday.
It's related to the behind-the-scenes work, which will be
revealed soon.
It will be revealed soon.
I'll be busy on Friday and Saturday.
So no streams on those two days.
Hey, guys.
Bye, everybody.
Bye.